Speaker 1: You don't need to go far. Or speculate
to know or predict what the MAGA right is going
to do tonight and tomorrow and over the next few
days. When it comes to the election results.
They are going to claim fraud. How do we know
this? Because they're telling us, much like we
figured out in the summer of 2020, that the Trump
campaign was going to be claiming fraud over mail
in ballots and other things in the 2020 election.
They're telling us they're going to do it. Here
is Trump lawyer Christina Bobb, who also is an
anchor on the right wing channel, right side
broadcasting. This is last night in Vandalia,
Ohio. And she says if any results are delayed
beyond early in the morning, tomorrow morning,
they are going to claim fraud. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: We do have a better chance of
knowing who won and who lost the election.
Speaker 2: I think so. I expect to know who
won by like the middle of the night, maybe
very, very early Wednesday morning. If we
don't and if Democrats try to extend the vote,
I think they're going to have a very, very hard
time doing it with any level of credibility.
Speaker 1: All right. Now, did you see what she
just did there? She did. She slipped something
in. That's totally incoherent. She says if we
don't have the results early tomorrow morning. And
Democrats try to extend the vote. No one is this
is no one's extending the vote. Extending the
vote is allowing more time for people to vote.
It's that's not even at issue here. Okay. She's
already mixing two different things and they
love to do this. One thing is just allowing
people to continue. The rules are clear.
You have to get your absentee ballots in. If
you're in line at the time that polls close,
you're allowed to vote. And beyond that,
that's it. Separately, there's the issue
of how quickly are votes counted. And
we'll get back to that in a moment.
Speaker 2: In 2020, they were able to do
it because they claimed COVID and they had
this excuse, which we all know was baloney,
because they had to go find more ballots and
do all of their ballot harvesting.
Speaker 1: None of that happened.
That's that's just a lie. There's
no evidence for that whatsoever.
Speaker 2: But I think that's going to be really
hard to do tomorrow, because everybody knows
what you should be able. There's no reason
you can't have a tally. And for a state,
let's say there's 4 million voters in Michigan
or Ohio and they get three, three and a half
million by midnight. You're telling me you
can't get to another half million and a
couple of hours? I mean, it's a no brainer there.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, what she doesn't mention is
that the reason that in a lot of the states they
stop counting at a certain time or it takes a
long time is because of rules that Republican
legislatures and secretaries of state have put
in place. Many states, as a result of laws enabled
by Republican legislatures, aren't allowed to even
start counting mail in ballots until after the
polls close. You could have the mail in ballots
counted as they come in or at designated times.
You could say okay, on November 7th will count
everything that's come in and we'll get a very
good jump start on getting those final numbers.
Republican legislatures in many cases say we
don't touch, we don't count anything until the
polls close. In other states, the legislatures
decide that you stop counting at a certain time
10:11 p.m. midnight. And you don't start until the
next day, no matter how close you are. So Kristina
Bobb now wants to make it make it seem it's very
suspicious. I mean, listen, if you're almost
done counting at midnight, just keep counting.
They passed laws saying that you can't do that.
And it is almost certain that, listen, we have
to know what to expect if Pennsylvania is close
and it may be very Shapiro's going to easily
defeat Mastriano, but odds Fetterman could be
very close. We could be talking about hundreds
or thousands of votes making the difference.
When they stop counting. We're not going to know.
And there's not going to be anything inherently
suspicious about that. These are the rules that
the state legislature put in place. So they
are telling us what they're planning to do.
They are going to use this to try to steal
some races, as they did in 2020. And we have
to be prepared. There's two things from a legal
standpoint. Democrats have to be prepared to
prevent shenanigans. But from an emotional
standpoint, we all have to be ready not to
react when they go, Oh, it's so suspicious. They
brought in ham sandwiches at 1130. It was the
wrong number of sandwiches and there were two
Orthodox Jews and they still brought ham. And
that's very suspicious. It's probably because
Fetterman stole it, right? We have to remember,
these. These people are nuts, okay? And not to get
fired up. We know what the processes are in states
like this. We went through the Pennsylvania thing
two years ago and not to allow them to rile us up.
But they're going to try. They're going to
claim fraud. Kerry Lake will claim fraud
in Arizona. She'll just claim victory if we
don't know the results. If she doesn't win,
they're going to do it. They're
telling us that they're going to do it.